is an extremely dangerous and upsetting  situation for farmers  right across  england who are losing their crops and  their equipment over the last 24 hours  because  of the temperatures and this prolonged  dry spell you can see here the  smoldering ground  this is completely torched this ground  it is still warm to the touch this fire  started  by  some of the equipment hitting shards of  flint combined with this material and  this straw and as that happens  it just smolders and usually the farmer  was telling me  the driver would have time to disconnect  the tractor move that away that's the  really expensive bit of equipment  and unfortunately let the other the  baler or the harvester burn there was no  time to do that he had to flee now  fortunately the driver of this equipment  yesterday here in wiltshire was unharmed  and was absolutely fine